hello everybody and welcome back to your
least favorite YouTube channel today
we're going to be talking about stream
processing and when I say stream
processing I certainly don't mean taking
a leak what I'm talking about is
real-time event processing so this
subject has a lot of content in it and
so I've split it into four hopefully
relatively small videos partially so
that I can cover them more in depth and
partially because I'm lazy and don't
want to make longer ones so let's go
ahead and get into it alright so for the
uneducated what exactly is stream
processing well the gist is so far in
terms of passing information around our
application we've really only spoken
about this through using a database
we've got one client or one application
server writing to a database and then
down the line another will read from it
however what if we want to be able to
react to things in real time as they
happen wouldn't it be great if one piece
of our application could pass something
like an event in real time to another
and it could react well that's what
stream processing is so stream
processing General framework is that
we've got some piece of our system
called the producer it is generating
events which are somehow passed over to
a consumer so obviously there's a lot of
different ways that we can do this but
let's start talking about how we could
so typically what we will do is use an
event or message broker so not always is
this the case actually oftentimes or not
necessarily often but infrequently what
you'll see are actually direct TCP
connections between our producers and
consumers certain designs do warrant
this or make sense to actually just
directly connect between those two
systems and pass messages from one to
another the issue with that however is
if you have many producers and many
different consumers all listening and
producing the same types of messages now
all of a sudden you're maintaining o of
N squared number of connections and
frankly that's a lot of load on these
systems that generally speaking are
probably going to be doing some other
type of processing and we'd rather not
bog them down
typically instead what we'll use is a
dedicated system known as a broker which
sits in the middle of our producers and
consumers and so this way as opposed to
having o of N squared connections we can
actually maintain a linear number of
connections because kind of the the
brunt of the work maintaining them is
actually done by the broker itself and
the broker's main job is to pass those
messages from producer to Consumer and
depending what type of broker you use
there's obviously going to be some
additional functionality but for the
sake of this video I'm actually not
going to dive too deep into the
architecture of a message broker there
are multiple different implementations
of these but right now what I'm going to
ask you to do is think of this thing as
a black box that simply passes messages
from the producer to the consumer and
then we're going to talk about certain
applications of stream processing and
why we would use it in the first place
so what are our main reasons for
actually using stream processing well I
can think of three of them and these are
the three that I'm going to touch upon
in order to introduce the subject in
this video the first is grouping and
bucketing of events
oftentimes by like a time stamp or a
Time window or a trailing time window
we'll see how we do that in a second
another is something known as change
data capture and then a third is known
as event sourcing two and three do seem
relatively similar but I'll explain the
Nuance in a little bit so let's take a
look at time windowing certain events or
metrics or anything like that so that we
can talk about them a little bit more
so imagine that we've got ourselves a
producer over here this could be
something like a sensor or an
application server that produces logs
and of course those messages are now
being sent right over here to the broker
which then forwards them to our consumer
now imagine that what we've got below is
effectively just a view of the state of
our consumer which again is doing all
the processing of these messages so
let's imagine that we wanted to bucket
them into something called tumbling
windows so a tumbling window as you can
see are non-overlapping windows that
start at a fixed interval with a fixed
time size so in this case what we're
looking at here are one minute tumbling
Windows starting at the beginning of
every single minute so how would we
actually deal with this well at every
single event is going to have a time
stamp
from the time stamp we can extract the
minute
and then we can bucket them in our
bucket we could probably use a hash map
on this to perform this well and then
our hash map would probably have some
sort of list of elements where all of
the elements are the messages themselves
so that is known as a tumbling window
another common task is where we actually
create a Hopping window where hopping
windows can actually overlap with one
another so for example here is one five
minute hopping window from 12 o'clock to
1204 but then 1201 to 1205 is a
different hopping window and 1202 to
1206 is a different five-minute hopping
window so how can we actually go ahead
and get all of the events that are in
these well if you notice every single
five minute hopping window is composed
of five non-overlapping tumbling windows
so we can effectively do the same thing
we did before group all of our messages
into tumbling windows and then when we
need a given five minute hopping window
we can just aggregate the five tumbling
windows that make them up so in the case
of 12 o'clock to 1204 this guy over here
we're taking the 12 o'clock we're taking
the 1201 we're taking the 1202 1203 and
the 1204 and so we would have events e h
c d i and G and the last type of task
that we'll often see in terms of just
like doing timing on events is known as
the sliding window where effectively you
know we just want let's say the last
five minutes of events so what we would
use here is an in-memory queue or an
in-memory linked list and basically as
events come in
you know we're adding them to the back
of our queue and then we have a separate
thread that's saying oh shoot it's 1207
now 1201 is no longer valid let's remove
that from our linked list and now just
this is going to be our last five
minutes of data so hopefully that makes
sense a little bit not overly important
but it is one common use case of stream
processing let's look at another called
change data capture now this is
something I use very frequently in a lot
of the systems design mock interviews so
it's important that we understand what
this really means basically the gist is
a lot of times we're going to be writing
to a database right we've got our client
here
we've got our database
and from there we've got a second piece
of storage that we basically want to
keep in line with our database right
we've got some other piece of derived
data
so in this case the derived data would
be our search index you don't really
have to worry too much about what a
search index is for now I'll cover this
in a later video but the gist is when we
have a write that goes to the database
we also want that right to be reflected
in our search index so as you can see
we've got one right from the database
it's going into our message broker and
then the message broker is of course
going to forward that to our search
index so that our search index can be
updated so change data capture is really
really useful for allowing us to keep
our derived data in sync with our main
database which tends to be our source of
Truth this is good because it allows us
avoiding things like two-phase commit
which is very expensive whereas you know
you wouldn't want to do a two-phase
commit between our search index and our
database it's a lot easier to just use a
message broker
okay another type of thing is event
sourcing which at first is going to seem
very very similar to change data capture
but there is some Nuance here so instead
of actually writing directly to your
database in this case what you're going
to do is you're going to send all of
these guys right here which are known as
events directly to a message broker the
message broker is then going to forward
those to a consumer and then finally
those messages are going to get to a
database where they can be properly
written so what's the advantage of
throwing everything in the broker first
well notice that I called these events
and not rights the reason they're called
events is because they use database
agnostic language as you can see the
type of things that we're doing here are
things like me clicking the cart or me
changing the quantity of an item in my
cart the reason for this is that in
change data capture the thing that's
actually going into the broker is not
database agnostic this is specific
to the database
and so when we have database agnostic
events that are going into our broker
basically meaning that you know they're
not actually specific to what database
we use or what the state of the database
was at the time it means that let's say
20 years in the future I want to use a
new database
I can actually just go ahead and read
from that broker and translate those
events however I see fit I don't need to
rely on this data model this data model
could be outdated
and if we don't care about it or for
whatever reason it's no longer working
for us it's no longer useful for us it's
a lot more useful to have all of those
raw events that would be in the broker
so the main issue here of course is that
does assume that the broker is actually
holding on to events which it very well
may not be again that is one of the
subjects of next video do we actually
keep these events do we throw them out
what goes on it depends really on what
type of event broker that you're using
so the last topic that I want to cover
in this video is exactly once message
processing or event processing so
processing a message exactly once means
two things it means that first of all
you're going to process that message at
least once how do we know that we can
process it at least once well we need a
few guarantees about our message broker
for starters it has to be fault tolerant
and typically when I say something is
fall tolerant what I really mean is that
there's some sort of like right ahead
log so you make sure that everything
that goes in there is on disk in the
event that your computer just shuts down
so that is going to be some disk
resistance and also replication because
if I come and I smash that computer with
a hammer you having those rights on disk
is probably not going to help you very
much you probably need a second instance
of that message broker that also has
access to the message another important
thing here is consumer acknowledgments
how is it that I know that a message has
been processed at least once unless the
consumer reports back to me on the
message broker that it has processed it
that is very important consumer
acknowledgments are something that
you'll typically see in just about every
single message broker
on the other hand we also need to be
sure that we don't process these
messages more than once so there are
basically two ways that we can do that
the first is two phase commit now if you
know every single time we talk about
two-phase commit in this channel
generally speaking it's bad we want to
avoid it wherever possible but in this
case what would that look like well just
quickly zooming in we would have a
coordinator node which at the same time
reaches out both to the consumer right
over here and the broker it says to the
broker hey can you delete this message
are you good to do that will it break
anything if you delete it the broker
will probably say yes I'm fine doing
that and then it'll also say to the
consumer hey are you able to handle this
message and if so are you ready to
commit it now if both of these systems
say yes then the coordinator can reach
back out to them
and say go ahead and actually commit
that you're good to go of course
two-phase commit always very slow and we
avoid it when possible which is why the
other nice thing that we can possibly do
is make our message broker item potent
or not necessarily our message broker
but the combination of our message
broker and our consumer so what item
potency means is if we were to process
the message more than once it's the same
thing as processing ones there are no
side effects to passing the message to
the consumer multiple times so what's an
easy way of doing this well basically
every single message on the broker gets
assigned a unique key and when the
consumer sees a message with said key it
can just respond saying whether or not
it's seen the key before and if that
message comes back again it'll see the
key one more time and then respond
accordingly saying I've seen this I'm
not going to process it again of course
this does make a key assumption about
how we're doing our partitioning or our
consumption of messages in the sense
that we are assuming that the same
consumer is seeing the same message
every single time if it's possible that
I can have two different consumers read
the same message from a message broker
then we're in trouble because one of the
consumers may have already seen it and
stored that item potency key but on the
other hand the other consumer wouldn't
have seen that key before and then we're
in trouble we've just processed the
message twice so again that is something
to think about in term in terms of how
you're laying out which consumers are
getting which message anyways guys hope
this serves as a good introduction sorry
I've treated the message broker as a
black box thus far but the whole reason
for that is we're going to spend the
entirety of the next video figuring out
what's actually going on inside there
and tearing up that box as they say so
anyway I will see you in the next one